the biggest superhero team-up of all
time for now has finally dropped
Avengers infinity war is a payoff of 10
years of storytelling done over the
course of nearly 20 films the movie
follows he avenges the guardians of the
galaxy and a smattering of other
superheroes as they take on the mad
Titan Thanos who seeks to assemble the
Infinity Gauntlet with the intent of
wiping out half of all life in existence
that obviously doesn't bode well for
existence so heroes from all across the
Marvel Cinematic Universe have to step
up and do everything they can to stop
him the film is a funny action-packed
and ultimately bittersweet romp that
somehow pulls off the ambitious
balancing act it sets out to accomplish
by the time it ends our heroes and the
universe a inhabit have been forever
changed it isn't perfect but it's pretty
damn near close obviously watch out for
some heavy-duty spoilers because we're
gonna ruin this movie's plot twist like
fan O's ruined well you'll see these are
the 5 best and 5 worst things about
Avengers infinity war best Hulk meets as
much you've got to start a movie like
infinity war off with a bang and this
one starts off with one heck of a wallop
we go put on the aftermath of Thanos his
assault on the Asgardian refugee ship
with bodies littering the floor but the
tide seemed to turn when Loki informs
Thanos that his team as a Hulk one-time
fans obviously caught this line as an
echo of his famous exchange I have an
army we have a Hulk
but once Loki is on the side of the big
green guy not that it ends up helping
this time around the slugfest of the
century follows albeit one that doesn't
quite go the way you'd think even
ambushing Thanos from a blind spot the
big green dude meets his match of the
mad Titan we've seen Hulk wreck every
hero in the MCU
but in this fight it becomes clear that
it's only because nobody can match his
strength but cuz he's had that to fall
back on he's never had to actually learn
to fight just smash with the help of the
purple Power Stone fallows is just a
strongest Hulk with the added bonus of
his own actual combat skills he
dismantles Hulk quickly and it's a
genuinely shocking moment setting the
tone for bigger even more depressing
surprises to come
worst a bad perspective Game of Thrones
actor Peter Dinklage appears in infinity
war as each Rey the giant dwarf who
forged Sauce hammer Marvel has a pretty
good track record of CGI transformations
via shrinking Chris Evans down to 90
pounds or turning Mark Ruffalo's
motion-captured hope performance into a
believable CGI character
unfortunately Dinklage's character
doesn't quite get that sort of
detail-oriented treatment it all comes
down to perspective in order for an
audience to properly gauge size
differences between characters we need
to see them standing in the frame with
one another it allows for the eyes to
assess the proportions of the characters
on screen and it's especially crucial in
dealing with characters who are
intentionally enlarged or shrunk
unfortunately while we can see that
Dinklage is character as a giant from
looking at his surroundings we don't see
him standing next to rocky or Thor
nearly long enough to fully understand
the size as a result he feels kind of
isolated and there's no perspective for
the characters build the I can't help
but notice something is off about him
because of the lack of perspective Lord
of the Rings this is not best the
brightest lights
Chris Hemsworth is a standout performer
in the MCU and infinity war might be a
better spotlight for him than any of his
solo movies
Thor is easily the standout character of
infinity war with a winning performance
from Hemsworth and an Odd Couple pairing
with rocky racoon the two head off into
space with teenage Groot in order to
find a new weapon for Thor that pairing
is funny and heartfelt but rather than
being played for non-stop laughs it
pulls back and reminds viewers just how
much Thor has lost over the course of
these movies while the character of
Thoreau's only gotten funnier his life
has gotten so much worse at the same
time everyone he loves is dead and he
feels much of the blame the rocket we
met in guardians of the galaxy would
have joked about this but this more
mature Rocky is actually a nice
companion but nothing
compares to Thor's triumphant return to
earth with his new weapon Stormbreaker
even without the Led Zeppelin soundtrack
from his last movie the god of thunder
has never looked more godly worst a
fatal fit of mischief there was a time
when you could argue that Loki was the
most dangerous character in the entire
MCU but the frequent co-star and
occasional villain ultimately becomes
more of a pest than a major threat on
the last Loki's Ark has still been a
compelling one despite getting something
of an unceremonious ending an infinity
war the god of mischief bites the dust
in the Films opening scene after
attempting to double-cross Thanos it's
quick and as dirty with his demise
ultimately just serving to fuel Thor's
arc in the film it's not the most
satisfying conclusion to the story of
one of the MC used most compelling
characters if Loki really is a goner we
can't help but wish he'd gone out a
little differently
best antihero villains have never been
the MCU strong suit above this movie
they not only made a great one they
actually made him the film's protagonist
obviously Thanos isn't the film's good
guy or anything but infinity war story
is structured entirely around him in his
quest he's the character he learned the
most about and the one whose story most
closely sticks to traditional three-act
structure we see him struggle make
difficult choices and then move forward
with the ramifications of those choices
it's sad as we see in the film's closing
shots looking out on a universe he now
believes to be a piece and obviously
everyone loves a good antihero when he's
this good at being bad we're just
getting started
nothing stops this train nothing worst
they'll be back the same actors comp
ladies characters forever so we all knew
some bad things were coming up in this
team-up when the film opens of Loki and
Holmes all getting taken out by Thanos
it sets the precedent from there the
movie doesn't let up as hero after hero
gets battered bruised and beaten
but while the film's devastating ending
features half of the life in the
universe crumbling into dust
it doesn't quite hold the weight it
should let's be real for a second does
anybody actually think all that these
characters are gone for good
of course not that's the tricky thing
about erasing the bulk of your cast from
existence
most of the audience can probably call
your bluff Gamora Loki and Heimdall's
deaths feel more permanent right now
because all these Marvel movies can
theoretically continue on
about them even we're the guardians of
the galaxy volume three having already
been announced the ones the rest of the
cast starts to drop namely all the
members of the next incarnation of the
Avengers it resonates more in the moment
due to how shocking it is the ultimate
goal of the movie is likely to focus
Avengers 4 on the original core cast all
of whom survived as much as we hate to
admit it
knowing that kind of makes the film's
shocking finale feel a little less
weighty after some thoughts best let it
breathe Marvel has had its comedic tone
unlocks since day one with Tony Stark's
quips an Iron Man but there is such a
thing as too much of a good thing
Marvel's movies have been known to
occasionally lead into the laughs at the
wrong moments using humor to stifle
emotional beats rather than let them
play out
[Music]
fortunately that doesn't happen so much
here there's plenty of humor throughout
the film but rarely does it come at an
inappropriate time for therapy session
with Rocky it goes uninterrupted Star
Wars realization like d'amour is dead
plays out to its fullest extent most
importantly the tragic ending is never
interrupted with the goofy quip this is
probably the single most important film
in the MCU and the fact that they
managed to balance a tone perfectly in
it makes for a much more satisfying
viewing experience worst cap it off with
dozens of different characters and plot
threads to balance it's only natural
that some characters are going to get
more screen time and character
development than others nonetheless
there's a weird bit of disparity in this
regard when it comes to Captain America
and dis crew Black Widow Falcon and
Winter Soldier Cup Secret Avengers are
on screen for a very solid chunk of the
film's running time but it's strange how
empty their time feels compared to the
Thorin Ironman parties who get plenty to
do emotionally it's not for a lack of
material either Steve Rogers in a very
difficult very interesting spot in the
wake of Captain America Civil War
lacking his signature shield and the
Stars and Stripes identity but an
infinity war Cap'n is ganger pretty much
just there to throw punches when they do
it's awesome but we seriously wish team
cap got a bit more of an engaging
emotional arc best sticking the landing
balancing 10 years 19 movies and dozens
of characters and plot threads make
infinity war without exaggeration one of
the most ambitious blockbusters of all
time there's so much going against a
movie that shouldn't work amazingly it
does the film as a whole is a triumph in
spite of itself
it lacks traditional structure there's
very little time for real character
development unless you count getting
cosmically turn to ashes character
development it also relies entirely on
the viewer having seen all 18 movies
leading up to it yet somehow it never
feels hindered by ambition in those that
what viewers want is a big bombastic
rollercoaster ride and it delivers all
while giving almost everyone in its cast
a great moment or two Avengers infinity
war should crumble under the weight of
its own ambitions that it stands tall
instead and makes almost three hours fly
by is a marvelous accomplishment all
right hey all right good job guys
let's just not come in tomorrow versus
take a day goober choice Wamba worst
accent amnesia Marvel Studios movies are
consistent they're consistently good
they're consistent in tone they're
consistent in quality of casting
decisions and performances but you know
what isn't consistent at all in Avengers
infinity war scarlet witch's accent
throughout her debut turn in Avengers
age of Ultron Wonder speaks with a thick
accent she mostly keeps it throughout
Civil War to birth elizabeth Olsen seems
perfect trouble committing to Wanda's
accent in infinity war one scene it's
there the next she sounds like well
Elizabeth Olsen of course exactly nobody
would particularly care if she just got
rid of the accent altogether but
constantly switching in and out of it
sometimes multiple times in the same
scene just makes it stand out
fortunately in a movie featuring a
talking raccoon magic stones and the
giant purple warlord is easy enough to
just ignore Scarlet Witch is magical at
disappearing accent thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to